what I'm about to show you will likely
blow your mind because by the end of
this video you will have seen
overwhelming evidence that a
mysteriously long-lost ancient human
civilization once spanned virtually our
entire planet and the implications of
that are incredible because it means
that what we were taught in school and
is still being taught and written about
in the textbooks is like really off from
what actually occurred in our human
history which is both amazing and
exciting when you think about it now I'm
about to show you more than 250 amazing
photos and comparisons of ancient sites
from around the world which none of them
seen by themselves prove widespread
global civilization but when brought
together and in comparison of other
ancient sites that are oceans apart it
becomes nothing short of actual proof
that there really was an ancient global
civilization that spanned virtually
every continent around the world and
you'll be left with the awkward question
which is how was I not aware of these
details before why is nobody in the
scientific or academic community talking
about this and bringing this information
to light like shouldn't this be in the
news or something because none of what
you're about to see is a secret it's
been writing in the open for thousands
and thousands of years which is partly
what makes it so mind-blowing the
widespread global extent of these
similarities are what made my jaw drop
and I'm willing to bet that you'll never
see these ancient sites the same way
ever again
now before I smother you with a couple
hundred photos and comparisons
let me first preface this video by
pointing out that the Roman Empire is
considered to have been the largest and
most widespread ancient civilization
ever known to have existed with the
Caesars controlling approximately one in
four people on earth during its height
nearly two thousand years ago this
included most all of modern-day Europe
the Mediterranean North Africa and
various places throughout the Mideast a
vast area especially for ancient times I
show you this map because for the rest
of the video I'm going to show you
dozens and dozens of striking
similarities from civilizations that are
not supposed to have had any
contact or connection to each other at
all having been separated by oceans and
continents so with that said here we go
perhaps one of the first things that
comes to mind when we hear the word
ancient ruins are the pyramids yet many
people are not aware that pyramids have
been found throughout five continents
around the world although most everyone
surely is familiar with not only the
Egyptian pyramids but the pyramids of
Central America as well along with
various pyramids with in Southeast Asia
in the country of Cambodia but let me be
clear it is firmly stated and taught in
the world of academics historians and
archaeologists that there is no
connection between ancient Egypt
Cambodia or Central America in fact it
is considered to be and I quote fringe
science pseudo history and pseudo
archaeology to suggest that it was
possible for these ancient civilizations
to have been connected across the oceans
and the continents in fact there have
been many books and scientific journals
written expressing just that but let's
take a second to compare the unique
similarities between the step pyramids
of Egypt the step pyramids of Central
America and the step pyramids of
Southeast Asia archeologists will tell
you that the similarity is simply
related to the primitive structural
design of the pyramids themselves and
that you starts with a larger foundation
and make each additional layer smaller
than the one below it they go on to
explain that this is the most simple
structural design possible and it's just
a matter of natural evolution within
varying civilizations to come up with
this design on their own again naturally
and organically I disagree however these
pyramid similarities are not a main
supporting argument for this video but
rather a start point but I have to say
that I do not think that these
similarities are just a coincidence
especially when you consider them from a
side-by-side comparison look and think
for yourself here's what I would argue
that although in today's world we are
separated by oceans and continents we
are still a global civilization that is
absolutely connected regardless of
country borders and different
governments
and in any corner of the earth in any
major city he will find skyscrapers and
although they're all different from each
other
they're still the same exact structural
concept made of steel concrete and glass
different in architecture yes but
essentially the same nonetheless in fact
the very first skyscraper started
somewhere which happens to be in Chicago
from there the concepts spread across
the world it is my opinion that the same
thing likely happened with the pyramids
and when you see what else I have to
share with you in this video you'll
understand why and like I mentioned a
few moments ago pyramids are found
across five continents around the world
and one place that I know most people
never knew of is Greece look at this
here and although much smaller compared
to other pyramids around the world is
undoubtedly very old and yet very
sophisticated made up of polygonal
stones that fit together like a
tight-fitted puzzle requiring no mortar
or concrete to hold them together simply
a makeup of intelligent mathematics and
precision and it's clearly been
weathered over what appears to be
thousands and thousands of years I
wonder how many people watching this
video had never seen or heard of this
Greek pyramid before particularly people
living outside of Europe and the
Mediterranean something else that you
may not be aware of involving ancient
Greece is that they have polygons o
stone walls a couple different places
around the country they've survived
thousands of years and some of the worst
earthquakes in human history most people
are not aware of the greece has
polygonal walls as you won't find this
structure design in and around athens
where all the other notable ancient
greek ruins are found and visited and
besides that when we typically think of
or hear of ancient polygonal stone walls
the ruins of south america in the
country of Peru likely come to mind
which I'll be discussing more of in a
moment
but just like the little-known stone
walls in certain places in Greece there
are also a few examples in Italy as well
again something most people do not
realize as you won't find an abundance
of this type of ancient stone structure
in and around Rome either and all the
other Roman tourist attractions take
attention away
just like in Greece it's also worth
mentioning that there are incredible and
massive polygonal stone walls in various
places in Turkey as well take a look at
these and again be reminded of the
massive stone walls in Peru definitely
not exactly the same but the concept
sure is and it's unbelievably difficult
of an undertaking to accomplish but that
aside and although these are certainly
credited to the Greeks and Romans we
have to ask ourselves why we find
something so strikingly similar all the
way over in Peru not only that we find
similar examples within ancient Egypt as
well this raises questions because as
far as we were taught there can be no
possible connection between the ancient
cultures of South America and Egypt or
to that of Greece and Italy however what
I'm about to show you next may take you
by surprise as there are several
examples of incredible ancient polygonal
stone walls all the way over in the
island country of Japan leave a comment
if you were completely unaware of these
walls and like I said there are a
variety of different examples of them
and I'm only showing you a few here in
this video but compared to the stone
walls of South America which although is
not exactly the same there we remind you
of my skyscraper analogy I gave moments
ago is this really just a coincidence or
a simple matter of organic human
ingenuity within different civilizations
that are worlds apart well if that's
what you think wait until what you see
next this is a stone box sarcophagus
found in ancient Japan now compare it to
a notable stone sarcophagus that made
headlines around the world in 2018 upon
its discovery with the whole world
waiting in anticipation for it to be
open so we could see what's inside I
made two videos on this if you're
interested but look at the design of the
stone lid and now compared to the stone
lid found in Japan both having somewhat
of a triangular shape although not
exactly the same however now compare the
Japanese stone lid to others that are
found in ancient Egypt Wow
this is beyond similar look at this and
think for yourself
I do not see a coincidence here I see a
connection an ancient connection that's
not supposed to be possible at all I
mean we're talking Egypt in Japan worlds
apart especially in ancient times and of
course according to the textbooks there
is no connection at all now remember the
Japanese polygonal stone walls I just
shared with you and that's head all the
way to the complete opposite side of
Pacific Ocean to remote Easter Island
which is more than two thousand miles
from the nearest point of South America
of course you know when we think of
Easter Island the notable moai statues
are probably the first thing to come to
mind many people are surprised when they
learned just how massive many of them
actually are once they've been dug up
and excavated just look at that however
what most of you are likely to find even
more surprising is to learn that there
is an example of a polygonal stone wall
on this island take a look at the
details of this wall I myself did not
know this existed until creating this
video as it's the moai statues that get
all the attention now compare this wall
to a wall all the way over in Peru look
at these comparisons and tell me that
this isn't a total match the
side-by-side comparisons definitely make
my eyebrow go up because the consensus
of academic scholars is that there is no
connection between Easter Island and
Peru it is also widely accepted that the
people of Easter Island came from the
Polynesian islands to the west and
settled on Easter Islands I do not
disagree with that at all
however let me quickly remind you of
something before I show you something
else which is that transoceanic sea
travel during this timeframe was
considered to be impossible and again to
suggest it is fringe and pseudo
archaeological like I stated earlier so
how do we explain the unbelievably
similar comparison to the little known
cloud people statues of Peru tell me
this isn't unbelievably similar and
again created at a time when travel
between Peru and Easter was not
considered a possibility but that's not
all compared these statues to others as
far away as Turkey and get this
Indonesia although not exactly the same
you look at the more nuanced details
such as hand positions and unique facial
and jaw structure I mean come on
is this also just a coincidence and then
we remind you that the site in Turkey
you see here gobekli tepe
is the world's oldest megalithic site on
earth dating back closer to 12,000 years
and was buried up until excavations
began in just the 1990s something you'll
find at this same site is the specific
stone carving of someone holding a
handbag this is a very unique and
specific connection that you will also
find all the way back in Mesoamerica
among the Olmec culture this is so
unbelievably similar and to think that
the bags themselves the stone carving
dates back 6,000 years earlier from our
first known document in civilization
which is the Sumerians which they
themselves have depictions holding this
bag and they are six thousand years
older than we are from present day right
now incredible how can something so
unique be just a coincidence however
that's what science community of
academics and archaeologists say about
it yet most people walking around
society have never even heard of this
before the authorities in the academic
world shun it yet they never even shared
it with you so you could think for
yourself
so what do you think about it having
seen about the these handbags for
yourself is it just a coincidence now
speaking of the Sumerians it's also
worth mentioning that they share another
similarity to that of ancient Greeks and
Hindu gods of ancient India which is the
depiction of the Trident but does this
prove a connection well by itself no but
that is not the only similarity shared
between these three separate cultures
for example the caduceus is the symbol
showing two snakes intertwined and found
throughout the modern world today among
the medical and healthcare industries
what most people do not know is it has
been found dating back as far as the
ancient sumerians of six thousand years
ago like I just mentioned well you may
find it interesting to learn that this
symbol was also utilized by the ancient
Greeks as well as in ancient India again
another interesting and specific
coincidence for three separate cultures
separated by time
and distance but it does not stop there
even look at the depiction of a Greek
god and Hindu god
battling a multi-headed snake now that
is a very specific and exclusive
similarity but again by itself it is not
earth-shattering
although Greece and India far apart the
ancient borders of the Greek Empire will
once not so far away from India during
the height of their civilization but you
would think that these interesting
details would be shared in school in the
textbooks as a possible link as a vast
majority of people out there have never
seen or heard of these details before it
seems to me that the ancient Greeks were
more connected to India than is
currently known or discussed but let me
keep going I'm sure everybody is
familiar with the incredible gold
funerary masks of the ancient Egyptians
but what's interesting is that this ties
into a similarity of the inca of Peru
and South America this is an incredibly
rare thing as well as I only found one
other culture that's and in only a few
cases also used gold funerary masks and
that was the Greeks but only in the
latter part of their civilization and
you know I have to say isn't it amazing
that the Egyptians were by far the best
the most highly skilled and
sophisticated makers of these gold masks
in comparison and they did so thousands
of years prior to the Inca or the Greeks
and speaking of gold masks notice the
depiction of a cobra snake at the
forehead something you'll also see on
countless stone statues of Pharaohs
within ancient Egypt
well now take a look at how the cobra
snake was depicted above the heads of
ancient Hindu gods here you can see just
a few examples and although not exactly
the same this is without a doubt a
specific similarity I mean why would
anyone think to depict this a cobra
snake at the head
of course you can read the explanations
provided by scholars which is not
consequential to this video but rather
the similarity itself is the
significance because there is absolutely
no known acknowledged connection between
ancient Egypt and ancient India but let
me keep going now
take a look at these examples of stone
nubs on ancient sites and indeed
many of you may have already heard me
and others share examples of these
unique stone nubs that are found in Peru
and Egypt here are some examples found
at Egyptian sites including even that of
a pyramid in Giza as well as at the
Assyrian as well and this is just to
show you a few examples now let me show
you a few examples found in Peru which
there are many examples at various sites
throughout this country and let me point
out real quick that I do not know the
purpose of these nubs but it is spare to
say that it's not related to moving or
lifting these stones as you would first
think because most of the stone blocks
do not have them only some of them do
Plus these nubs are found on various
bedrock stones which obviously had no
intention of being moved and or lifted
here are just a few examples to share
what I mean by that so whatever their
purpose was it's not important to the
point that I'm trying to make although
it's a fun discussion for another video
the point I'm making here is to show you
the widespread global nature of these
nubs and let me say this real quick
that's even if the purpose of these
stone nubs involved moving or lifting
the stones themselves then I would argue
that it's even more supportive evidence
of a widespread global connection I mean
we have different ways of moving and
lifting stones today and we are a global
civilization that pretty much uses the
same exact technology right so if there
was some sort of purposeful stone mark
on any stone that we're moving or
lifting that would be because we're
using the same technology to do so so if
we find these stone nubs across the
world as you're about to see then you
could argue that it's more supportive
evidence that the ancients had a
widespread global connection but getting
back to the widespread phenomena of the
nubs here are a few additional examples
at various sites in India and again
notice that they're on some but not all
of the stones I'll be curious to see
comments of how many people that were
already aware of these nubs in Egypt and
Peru who were only just now learning of
these nubs being in India as well leave
a comment if you are but here's where it
becomes even more thought-provoking as
these nubs are at sites all over the
world
for example even at an ancient quarry in
China I'd be curious to know if there
are other examples found at ancient
sites in China which is not easy to
learn as many sites are closed off to
the public lame right but you'll even
find an example of nubs in Japan which
is interesting when you consider what I
already pointed out involving the
polygonal stone walls within Japan as
well and especially the comparison of
the stone sarcophagus to the ones found
in Egypt but even if we head to the
remote Micronesia island of Palau where
there is at least one example of nubs on
another psycho figgus I'd be curious if
there were other examples that existed
on the island which I bet if there is
one there's more even as we head west to
islands of Indonesia where I already
shared the fascinating similarity
between the moai statues of Easter
Island Peru and Turkey well you will see
also see examples of nubs here as well
and if you look closely you will see
more than just a few that grab your eye
when you first see the image but I
really wasn't kidding when I said that
these nubs are all over even if we head
back to Africa to the country of
Ethiopia you can see nubs on a stone
sarcophagus there as well and if we head
to the neighboring country of Sudan to
where most people don't even realize
also has pyramids and of incredible
precision although much smaller than
those of the Pyramids of Giza but
someone please tell me what on earth
happened to make half of these just
blown up or ripped apart in half
notice that what on earth is that about
but if we look closely and I'm sorry
that the pictures are not of the best
quality you will see nubs in some of the
stones and keep in mind that these stone
blocks are much larger than you realize
and so are the nubs so these are not
just blemishes hopefully we can get our
hands on better photos of these pyramids
and other nubs that may be found on them
but even if we head to Europe you will
find examples of nubs in various
countries including Bulgaria and again
notice that the nubs are on some but not
all of the stone blocks as well like I
mentioned at other locations but we can
even find examples of nubs in Syria
again on some blocks but most are
without
them and if we head to Greece there are
a couple locations that have them as
well interesting though that we don't
find these nubs in Athens at least from
what I saw and if they are they
certainly are not in abundance on the
most popular ancient sites we normally
see from the ancient Greeks and the
tourist attractions that are there in
Athens even if we head to the Italian
island of Sardinia which is in the
middle of the Mediterranean Sea there
are examples of Nub's there as well same
thing if we head to Turkey where you can
find an abundance of nub examples at
various sites throughout the country but
for brevity of this video I'll show just
a few to display the connection but let
me interject real quick here since I
just mentioned that there are nubs found
in Italy and in Greece and elsewhere
around the Mediterranean because some
people might jump to the conclusion that
hey wait a second this is just a matter
of the Greeks or the Romans but that
can't be the case because as we know
there are nubs in Japan they're nubs in
Peru there's none Indonesia and
elsewhere so if that were the case that
it was just simply Oh a Roman or a Greek
thing then why do we not see more
examples of these one within their
capitals all over the place within the
notable tourist attractions that we
always see in here about as well as the
fact would have to say hey we're the
Romans or the Greeks capable of
traversing the ocean at vast distances
because that would completely contradict
what we learned in school as well and
what the scientific community say is
even possible so something to think
about so with that said it seems to me
that at a minimum based on what we've
seen so far the widespread nature of
these ancient nubbed phenomena and these
other aspects we've shared so far in the
video that at a minimum it shows that
regardless the ages of these things or
who made them that at a minimum there's
far more to the story of what we thought
we knew about our ancient past as it is
regardless of the age or who did it
there's clearly something more that we
don't know about now let me keep going
because I have more to share so in
previous videos I've shared unique
comparisons between angled structures of
ancient sites in Peru to that of Egypt's
and these are just a couple examples now
I've also shared examples of that of
trapezoidal doorways so let's head back
to ancient sites within India look at
this here cut out of solid stone make no
mistake these symmetrical angles would
made the construction far more difficult
to do compared to a straight line and
I'll give further supporting evidence of
that in a second but look at these
various different trapezoidal doorways
first now let's head to the opposite
side of the world again to South America
this first notice the cutout itself
which is not exactly the same as in
India but similar and with great
precision and equally difficult to
accomplish now look at just a couple
examples of trapezoidal doorways in
various places throughout Peru
of course not exactly the same as within
India
as these sites in Peru utilize separate
stones rather than just one solid stone
cut out but to emphasize my point that
the trapezoidal design is far more
difficult than straight lines you have
to appreciate that it would be far
easier to cut a bunch of square or
rectangular stone blocks of the same
exact dimensions and then stack them
upon each other into the design of a
doorway but when going the route of a
trapezoidal design each layer a block is
a different shape than that of the one
above or below it in order to achieve
the symmetrical angle that right there
is next level difficulty now again this
is not exactly the same as in India but
they remind you again of the example
evolving the skyscrapers across the
world all different types of
architecture none are the same but there
is still essentially the same thing just
different it's worth mentioning that
these are not the only examples of
trapezoidal doors you'll find around the
world though in fact a certain place in
Italy has trapezoid doors and this
feature can even be found in ancient
Egypt as well isn't that interesting and
real quick the site here in Italy is in
Lazio and it was a tomb take a look at a
few different photos here observed not
just the shape of the doorway but also
the windows and notice that it has false
windows as well now let's compare that's
to Peru and tell me that this isn't
incredibly similar in fact when you
compare how there are sites that have
both real and false windows and of the
same unique trapezoidal shape and in
combination of the other same style
trapezoidal doorways also found in Peru
we just shared this should make you
wonder but again none of these details
seem by themselves prove global
connection you have to look at
everything from the whole now I had a
career as a corporate fraud investigator
where I would investigate employees that
were suspected of stealing and
defrauding the company and I would
gather evidence and build a case that
would eventually lead to an arrest and
prosecution and what I can tell you is
that in the court of law regardless of
the crime that if you don't have you
know caught red-handed on videotape or
something of the crime what you do is
you build up a bunch of points of
evidence line items of evidence at this
place at this time and you gathering
together and eventually all those lines
of evidence lead to what's considered
proof and will lead to a conviction so
let me ask you this when you look at all
the information that I've shared so in
this video all the physical evidence the
details is it really just a coincidence
or when you piece it all together and
you look at all the information together
as opposed to individually because you
could write anything off Oh a
trapezoidal door it's possible access to
coincidence the tridents coincidence all
of this could be just a coincidence and
inconsequential when you look at it by
itself but when you bring it all
together it does this not amount to
actual proof that clearly there's far
more going on and our ancient past and
what we ever thought I mean let's review
real quick we have gold funerary masks
among three separates and far apart
cultures that are supposed to have no
connection to each other at all we have
depictions of Cobras snakes at the head
of two different cultures along with
depictions of the caduceus among three
different cultures along with the pic
shion's of the Trident among those
cultures depictions of handbags edged in
stone separated by in some cases tens of
thousands of years when you consider
gobekli tepe to the connection of the
Olmecs in Mesoamerica I mean really is
that detail just a coincidence how
specific can we get we also have the
creepy similarity of the moai statues to
others in Peru Turkey and Indonesia we
also have a bizarre similarity between
Egypt and Japan when you consider that
stone box sarcophagus and how similar
they both look and having had no
connection between those two cultures
that were
depart we also have polygonal stone
blocks found throughout the world
ranging from Easter Island Peru Egypt
Japan and throughout the Mediterranean
and we also have the Stone dub phenomena
that are found across the world
including again Japan Micronesia
Indonesia Egypt Peru and again
throughout Africa and Europe consider
all of that and now take a second look
at the similarities between the Pyramids
of Egypt Cambodia and Central America do
these side-by-side comparisons really
suggest a simple and natural evolution
of structural design that are totally
organic and natural within itself or is
it when you study the specific and truly
unique aspects and in combination with
everything else shared in this video
does it seem to be more than just a
coincidence academics profusely rejects
an ancient global connection or
civilization of any kind and they
ridicule others that suggests it with
essentially name-calling you know words
like Fringe and pseudo yet they never
actually go through and share all of the
details with those who they intend to
persuade look at all these details that
I've shared in this video and think for
yourself and isn't it interesting that
none of these things were shared with
you in school at all in fact only a very
small percentage of people have seen
some of these details before of course
there are ancient history enthusiasts
that watch this channel that are
subscribed there other youtubers I'm not
the first to talk about these things
although I can tell you that while
researching this topic in the last
number of weeks that many of these
things I was blown away my jaw dropped
seeing the connections between Japan and
Easter Island and elsewhere around the
world that this this adds up far more
than I thought I was already suspicious
and thought that there was a global
civilization I think a lot of people
that watch this channel and are
enthusiasts for the topic of lost
ancient civilizations they already knew
it but were they aware of the extent of
all of this I don't think it's a
coincidence but that's not to say that
we should just start rewriting the
textbooks right this second but at a
minimum what is necessary is a whole new
conversation and debate and
these details should at least be
presented to the younger generation that
is currently in school now because keep
in mind this stuff is shunned right even
people that study this stuff are
oblivious to a lot of these same little
details right so with that being said
there's gonna be a whole new generation
of academic scholars and archaeologists
and historians that it would be great
for them to be raised with a more open
mind because what happens is people are
raised into being told one thing and
then they grew up thinking the same
thing and then when you leave here's
something you as an adult
they're like wait that's not true if
that was true I already would have heard
about it but again it goes back to my
point that how many of these deity
details have you never seen or heard of
before and how is it that the people
that are saying that no it's all fringe
but they're not when I say they talk
about friends and things I shared with
you they're not responding to these
details they just say that transoceanic
connections was impossible that only
started happening a few hundred years
ago and that's that you're crazy you're
a pseudo historian or archaeologist
you're fringe if you think otherwise
but they don't share with you the same
details while trying to persuade you
when they say it think about that and
then we also say that I'm not
necessarily suggesting that every single
location was connected to every other
single location that I just presented in
this video let me go back to my example
of the skyscrapers how it originated in
Chicago I am suggesting that in that
comparison that when one thing starts
somewhere it eventually spreads goes
different places and that's what I think
happened in ancient times and they were
far more global than what they get
credited for now let me say that there
is an abundance of more information that
exists that I did not share in this
video I don't ups polygonal blocks and
many other fascinating aspects my
intention in this video was to share the
widespread nature I reached out to a
fellow youtuber named Andrew who runs a
channel called ancient history
criticisms and he's been cataloging
these connections in epic detail
particularly the nubs and other
stonework this guy played a huge part in
helping me with this video I asked him
for some help and some insight and he
truly went above and beyond asking
anything that I had asked for he
he's made dozens of videos that are a
goldmine for this ancient connection
topic and look he is barely over a
thousand subscribers so hook him up go
to his channel right now and hit the
subscribe button make this guy's day he
truly deserves it and he has so much
potential and he has so much information
to share that so many other people
should know about but when you're a
small Channel it's hard to get the word
out so follow him on social media as
well he's a smart guy and he's worthy of
your time so definitely go and subscribe
to his channel right now but anyways
guys I'm Jimmy my channel is called
bright insight hit the like button and
subscribe and leave a comment and let me
know what your thoughts are and
everything that's been discussed and
it's important to acknowledge that I am
not the first to be discussing these
things I'd like to think that I shared a
number of things that were never shared
about from other researchers in the past
involving this ancient global connection
but there are many other researchers
that have talked about this for decades
and it's important for people to realize
that guys there's so much waiting to be
discovered that's not a secret
and it's hiding in plain sight so
anyways I'll leave it at that
I'm Jimmy this bright insight hit the
like button subscribe my dogs are
barking take care everybody